das tier hinter mir das ist der kleine
logen und vielleicht kennt ihr ihn aus
den youtube videos oder instagram
stories seiner mama held at any annika
baldi dort viele viele follower hat und
jetzt ist den beiden das schlimmste
passiert was mama und sohn passieren
kann der kleine wurde entführt
verschleppt nach thailand vom ex-mann
und genau dorthin sind wir jetzt gereist
und haben uns auf die spurensuche nach
den kleinen logan gemacht es ist der
albtraum jeder mutter das eigene kind
tausende kilometer ins ausland entführt
kein kontakt kein lebenszeichen seit
mehr als drei monaten ist annika ball
genau in diesem alptraum gefangen am 24
september entführt annikas ex mann den
zweijährigen gemeinsamen sohn logan ins
ausland ich habe nur geweint